Hey Thoughty2 here and welcome to the Schaerbeek,
one of the nineteen municipalities of Brussels.
On the 18th May 2003 Schaerbeek held a location
election using electronic voting machines.
All was going well until the votes were counted
and it was noticed that one candidate received
4,096 extra votes that couldn't have been
possible, considering the total number of
voters that attended.
This wasn't just a small anomoly, this was
a major hiccup, something had gone seriously
wrong with the vote.
There was a large investigation and the electronic
voting machines used in the election were
thoroughly checked over.
Even the source code for the software was
scrutinised to try and find a bug that would
explain 4,096 votes out of nowhere.
But it wasn't a software bug, it was caused
by something that no one could have anticipated,
a charged particle from outer space.
Several hundred light years away, and hundreds
of years ago a star exploded in a galaxy far,
far away.
This violent supernova emitted cosmic rays,
trillions of highly charged particles of matter.
They will travel through space indefinitely
at close to the speed of light.
But one of these particles set off on an epic
mission, a lifelong goal it was determined
to achieve: to disrupt the Belgium local elections
of 2003.
This tiny terrorist traveled through the inky
black for hundreds of years.
It finally reached Earth, and in a show of
defience penetrated its magnetic field, before
slamming into a microprocessor in the core
of an electronic voting machine in Brussels.
This caused a single bit within the computer's
memory to flip from a 0 to a 1, known as a
"bit flip" and thus a spectacular chain reaction
happened within the computer's code, which
caused 4,096 votes to materialise from nothing
and register themselves against one particular
candidate.
If this error hadn't have been noticed by
officials, the wrong candidate would have
been elected that year.
But this isn't some super-rare event.
Planet Earth is constantly being bombarded
by trillions of charged particles from outer
space and your electronic devices are continually
at the mercy of this radiation.
Have you ever been typing up an essay and
just before you hit save your computer freaks
out and you receive the ominous "blue screen
of death"?
In many such cases it may have been caused
by a charged particle from space hitting your
computer's processor and causing a total system
crash.
But it's not just antiquated Window's machines
that suffer from tiny invisible space invaders.
Galactic particles cause errors, bugs and
crashes on your smartphones, smart watches,
tablets, televisions and terrifyingly, even
your car's on-board computer.
In fact such events are so common they have
been given a name, they are called Single
Event Upsets or an "SEU".
They have been giving computer engineers and
developers a major headache since the dawn
of computer processors.
Forever causing completely unexplainable issues
and crashes that just shouldn't have happened.
We could just ignore the issue, after all
we've put up with it for all this time, we
just get angry when it happens, slam our keyboard
against the wall and continue our day acting
as though a slight computer glitch didn't
get under our skin and cause us to flip the
hell out.
But we simply can't ignore SEUs, because they
can be deadly.
In October 2008 Qantas flight number 72 was
midflight on the way from Singapore to Perth
Airport in Australia.
When suddenly, with no warning the plane's
autopilot system disabled itself, causing
the plane to freefall rapidly, for 23 seconds,
before pilots regained control and safely
made an emergency landing.
One third of the passengers were seriously
injured due to the massive g-force suffered
from the sudden freefall.
A lengthy investigation took place and it
was discovered that the autopilot was turned
off by a computer error causes by an SEU.
The most likely explanation is that a highly
charged particle from a cosmic ray, trillions
of miles away in space had hit the computer's
processor, wreaking havoc.
The higher up in the atmostphere you go the
more prone your electronics are to SEUs, because
many of the particles entering Earth are stopped
before they reach the ground.
This means planes are particularly at risk.
Whether we like it or not our world is run
almost entirely by computers.
Our bank balances are bits on a computer hard
drive, our cars park by themselves and will
very soon drive themselves.
Computers power the vast majority of conversations
that take place every day across the globe.
Every piece of information we now receive
comes from computers and they influence every
decision we make.
So in a world so dependant on computers it's
only a matter of time before an invisible
cosmic particle causes an SEU somewhere in
the world that completely distrupts a major
computer system.
The fallout could be enormous.
Just imagine, if for example a particle caused
an SEU on a major federal server somewhere,
causing the banks to collapse and the GDP
of the United States to drop from 18 trillion
dollars to 18 dollars overnight; Trump could
finally lose his shit and nuke the World,
because of a single atomic particle.
Okay I may be hyperbolising, but it could
happen... maybe.
So what do we do to defend against these atomic
anarchists?
Well we already are and we have been doing
for almost three decades.
In the early 90s IBM and some other computer
manufacturers realised they had to come up
with a way to make computers more reliable
if they were ever going to sell them en-mass
to consumers and even more so to businesses
who needed servers that they could rely on
24/7.
So a few tech companies came up with the idea
of parity.
Computers speak in bits, its their language
in its most primitave form.
A single bit is the smallest unit of data
in a computer and it can either be a 1 or
a 0.
Put all these bits together and suddenly you
have words, for example this may look like
nonsense to you and I...
01001110 01101111 01100010 01101111 01100100
01111001 00100000 01100101 01111000 01110000
01100101 01100011 01110100 01110011 00100000
01110100 01101000 01100101 00100000 01010011
01110000 01100001 01101110 01101001 01110011
01101000 00100000 01101001 01101110 01110001
01110101 01101001 01110011 01101001 01110100
01101001 01101111 01101110 00101110
...but to a computer this reads as "Nobody
expects the Spanish inquisition."
Take the first eight numbers "01001110" which
translates as "N", this group of eight bits
is called a byte.
But all it takes is to change the last digit
of this byte from a zero to a one and its
translation changes completely, from an N
to an O.
Now this is where parity comes in.
Computer scientists had the genius idea of
adding a ninth digit to the end of every byte,
an extra zero or one, this extra digit is
called a "parity bit".
If all eight digits add up to an even number
then the parity bit will be a zero, representing
even and if not, then a one is added, representing
odd.
And therefore you know it's a valid byte,
if a byte is received by the computer's processor
that adds up to an odd number but the parity
bit is a zero, suggesting it should have added
up to an even number, then the computer instantly
knows that there's an error in the byte, potentially
caused by an SEU.
But merely detecting errors wasn't enough.
It's not just cosmic radiation that's corrupting
memory but nearby magnetic fields and the
ironising background radiation of the Earth
itself.
Even the temperature of the room the computer
sits in can create software hiccups and cause
crashes.
So people with really long beards, because
as we all know, you're not a computer scientist
unless you have an impressive beard, ladies
excluded.
Took parity bits one step further and invented
a genius way for computers to not only detect
when an error has occured but self-correct
it.
. and so ECC memory was born, short for error-correcting
code memory.
When an error is detected via a byte's parity
bit the ECC memory goes back to the code that
created the byte and double checks everything
using special algorithms.
Once it has discovered what the true value
should have been, it simply corrects it quietly
and gets on with its life and the human behind
the screen is non-the-wiser that their computer
just saved them from a blue screen of death
and a whole load of stress.
So if this miraculous ECC memory exists then
why does my computer, smartphone and tablet
still crash occasionally and why are planes
falling out of the sky?
Well ECC memory is slighly more expensive
than regular, non-ECC memory, so most consumer
computers are built with non-ECC memory, meaning
they can't self-correct.
ECC memory is typically used in mission critical
applications for example by banks, and in
server farms where abosolute reliability is
essential to their business and a minute of
downtime could literally cost millions of
dollars.
And yes I know what you're thinking, they
didn't think that the the lives of hundreds
of humans on a plane didn't warrant ECC memory,
but financial trading does, yeah.
Don't worry, since that incident, the reliability
of on-board aeroplane computers has been significantly
improved.
But even with ECC memory in your computer
you're not immune to crashes, far from it.
It can protect you from cosmic rays and radiation,
sure, but some crashes are simply caused by
poor and shoddy programming, or software that's
riddled with bugs, and there's plenty of that
to go around.
So we've found a solution to cosmic ray bombardment
here on Earth but the problem is a thousand
times worse once you leave Earth's protective
atmostphere.
Out in space the amount of cosmic ray abuse
one suffers is many thousands of times higher.
Apollo astronauts reported seeing a streak
of white light across their field of vision
every 3 minutes, whilst out in space.
Even when they closed their eyes.
It was explained to them that this was caused
by cosmic rays hitting their optic nerve,
causing it to temporarily glitch and crash.
As you can imagine cosmic rays play havoc
with satellites and spacecraft, but they can
also save them.
In 2015 the privately funded space exploration
programme "The Planetary Society" launched
a groundbreaking data-gathering spacecraft
into space, called LightSail, that would use
a large, reflective sail to propel itself
through space using photons emitted from the
Sun.
But soon after it reached outer space the
onboard software crashed and LightSail ceased
all communication with Earth.
The engineers back on Earth knew that the
crash was caused by a memory leak and all
that was needed was a total system reboot.
See, even rocket scientists fix their computer
issues by turning it off and back on again.
For eight days the spacecraft drifted through
space, completely dead.
The engineers had almost lost hope, when suddenly,
a cosmic ray from a galaxy many millions of
miles away, hit the on-board microprocessor
in just the right place, which caused the
software to reboot itself.
The engineers were amazed that suddenly they
were receiving messages once again from the
craft.
There are over 4,500 artificial satellites
currently orbiting Earth and they are crucial
to our every day life in the modern age.
We use them for navigation, to predict the
weather, for business and finance, communication,
television and many other uses.
It's therefore of the upmost important that
they don't crash on us.
They use a multitude of techniques to do this,
such as physical shielding using thick, heavy
metals and ECC memory.
NASA however were so concerned about the threat
of cosmic rays upon their spacecraft's on-board
computers that they devised a devastatingly
simple yet enormously effective solution to
solve the problem once and for all.
Instead of putting one processor chip inside
the craft they put three identical chips in
there.
When the computer needs to calculate something
it is calculated on all three processors simitaneously
and the results are compared, if one processor
produces a different result from the other
two then the computer knows it's wrong.
The likelyhood of a cosmic ray causing an
SEU on one processor out in space is quite
high, but the chance of it happening to two
or more processors at the same time and causing
the exact same error is vanishingly small,
making the three processor solution extremely
reliable.
Which just goes to show that sometimes the
most complex of problems requires the simplest
of solutions.
Thanks for watching.
I'm really excited to announce that you can
now get a high quality, Thoughty2 t-shirt,
mug and poster every month by simply heading
over to patreon.com/thoughty2 and becoming
a Patron.
I will be designing a new t-shirt, mug and
poster every month based on videos I've released
that month and sending them out to my Patrons.
Not only will you get awesome rewards in the
post each month, and early access to all my
videos, but you'll also be helping this channel
to make better videos through your support,
so thank you.